Bone Dusters Paleo Ale is beer made from a
35 million year old whale fossil.
And this face aging progression uses thousands
of online photos of people the same age to
show you what your toddler will look like
in 80 years.
Vsauce!
Kevin here.... this is Mind Blow.
Three London design students have created
edible water bottles.
The blobs called Ooho cost only two cents
to make are hygienic and biodegradable.
The water is held inside a double membrane
made from algae and calcium chloride that
works similar to an egg yolk.
The hopes are that this can one day be a substitute
for the large amount of water bottles thrown
away every year but packaging is currently
a challenge.
Zuta labs is creating a miniature mobile printer.
They shrunk the size of a traditional printer
by moving the printhead onto a small omni
wheel system that runs across the page.
It's battery charged, connects directly to
a smart device or PC and prints on any size
paper.
Each ink cartridge can print 1,000 pages and
you simply line up the corner of the device
to the corner of the paper to ensure that
the print is straight.
Biomedical Engineers at Duke have grown living
skeletal muscles that heal themselves.
It's the first time that engineered muscle
has been able to contract as strongly as native
skeletal muscle.
Native muscles have stem cells known as satellite
cells on reserve to start regenerating muscle
as soon as an injury happens.
The key to this latest success was creating
micro environments where the satellite cells
could sit and wait until they were needed.
To prove the engineered muscles' ability,
they injected it with snake venom to see if
the satellite cells would activate and repair
the damaged muscle.
And they're looking to discover if this new
technology can repair actual muscle injuries
and disease.
Stanford Engineers are creating a video game
controller that senses emotions and adjusts
the gameplay depending on how you feeling.
They measure pulse and respiration rate as
well how much the players hands are moving.
So for instance if your heart rate goes down
the game could send in more zombies to make
it more exciting or if parents worried their
kids are getting too amped up they can have
the game set to slow it down in that instance.
The body dryer is a bacteria-free drying system
that eliminates the need for towels.
After choosing between hot or cold air, It
takes only 30 seconds to fully dry by forcing
super compressed ionized air up and the water
down off your body.
Reza Montazami of Iowa State is developing
dissolvable electronics.
He and his team have created a degradable
antenna that is capable of data transmission.
And they hope this technology could lead to
future medical devices that melt inside the
body or military devices that dissolve if
information gets into the wrong hands.
This urban vegetable garden can grow 970 sq
meters worth of produce in only 16 sq meters.
The LED lights help grow plants faster using
a system that can control the illumination
strength depending on the stage of the plant
reducing an average two and a half month growing
period down to only one month.
And the technology has been in place since
2010 but is now being installed regularly
in Japan.
The PL01 is a tank concept that can turn invisible
to infrared detection.
Using hexagonal plates that cover the exterior
they control the temperature of the tank to
match the surrounding heat signature.
This way the tank seems invisible to infrared
targeting sensors that are often mounted on
drones and missiles.
And the functional prototype is due in 2016.
A 23 hour surgery resulted in a woman receiving
a 3D printed plastic skull.
It was the first time an entire cranium was
replaced with a plastic skull - implants were
previously made by hand using a cement-like
material.
But 3D printing allows surgeons to make more
precise prosthetics that can be designed down
to the cellular level which significantly
lowers the risk of the body rejecting them.
.
Finally, Slow Life by Daniel Stoupin speeds
up the constant, but unnoticed movement of
coral and sponge marine life.
I'm going to leave you with a dynamic, machine-driven
shape display that visualizes streams of data.
For more incredible virus footage check out
"5 reasons Why Viruses Make The Perfect Villain"
over on Head STEAM - while you're there make
sure you subscribe and as always...
thanks for watching!